it's good to be back um
yeah it's been five years um
doesn't look like a lot's changed just
two months after walking out of prison
martin shkreli is launching a new
business his new software platform helps
anyone model chemical compounds to
design new drugs for free contributors
are paid in the official crypto martin
shkreli enu which has recently crashed
following an alleged hack it was his
previous involvement with the drug
industry that made the pharma bro famous
a few years ago shkreli notoriously
hiked the price of a life-saving drug by
more than 5 000
in response to all of this attention and
doctors and patient groups saying they
can't access this drug are you going to
change the price no he was called the
most hated man in america after raising
the price of a tablet of dareprim from
13.50
to
750
i probably would have raised the price
higher
this is probably what i would have done
so how did a guy who started two hedge
funds in his 20s end up founding touring
pharmaceuticals he has a ba in business
administration from a city college in
new york yet made the switch because
there wasn't enough money in hedge funds
you could say that that is the biggest
[ __ ] answer ever as he admitted to
vanity fair
in 2015 turing pharmaceuticals acquired
the rights to dareprim which treats a
rare infection from the parasite
toxoplasmosis babies born to women
infected during pregnancy can go blind
or suffer brain damage and it can be
fatal in people with compromised immune
systems such as those living with hiv
there's no excuse from going from 13.50
to seven hundred and fifty dollar for
one pill and he looks like a spoiled
brat to me you wanna know the truth he
looks like a spoiled brat a spoiled brat
is far from the way he grew up shkreli
was born in brooklyn in 1983 to
immigrants from albania
his father worked as a doorman both his
parents also held all jobs as janitors
to support him his brother and two
sisters he's described himself as the
most successful albanian on earth yet
many described him differently targeting
him as the arch villain of the pharma
industry a symbol of modern day greed
what shkreli did was actually not new
drug companies have a history of raising
prices yet they didn't generate the
headlines shkreli did perhaps because he
was so unapologetic about it no one
wants to say it no one's proud of it but
uh you know this is a capitalist society
capitalist system and capitalist rules
and my investors expect me to maximize
profits not to minimize them or go half
or go 70 but to go to 100
of the profit curve
that we're all taught in in mba class it
didn't help that as people complained
that health care in america was becoming
unaffordable he betrayed himself as a
wealthy hedge fund guy dishing out 2
million at an auction to buy the one and
only copy of an unreleased wu-tang clan
album and when congress grilled him over
the price hike he trolled them do you
think you've done anything wrong
on the advice of council
i invoke my fifth amendment privilege
against self-incrimination and
respectfully declined to answer your
question is it pronounced shkreli yes
sir see there you can answer some
questions that one didn't incriminate
you
and i truly believe
i truly believe
are you listening
yes he didn't say much during the
hearing but he's defended his actions as
having minimal impact on the healthcare
system because daraprim is only used by
around 2 000 americans he said for those
without insurance his company would sell
daraprim for just a dollar a pill noting
more than half of his patients get it
for a buck for everyone else insurance
would cover the cost there isn't
consequences they have insurance i don't
know if you're familiar with healthcare
insurance i've heard of it yes 90 of
americans have it our president forced
us to get it i think do you remember
that yet health care insurance companies
claim they have been forced to raise
their rates due to the rising cost of
drugs when you have for example the
health insurers pay really high prices
that gets expressed through premiums
sooner or later it doesn't just go away
of course it does and and so the
question is as uh gdps grow and we're
we're at the top of that pack right
we're the leader by a long shot i think
what happens is that we learn as a
society that what we prize in life is
our health and we're going to spend more
and more on our health than ever before
and that's a good thing i think it's a
mark of a civilized country
israeli claims his price hike was for
the greater good that he takes some of
the profit and puts it into research to
invent a better drug the least you can
do the least you can do is take those
profits
and help those patients even more by
making a better drug like therapy is 70
years old quite frankly it is not a
great drug nevertheless daraprim remains
the gold standard for treating
toxoplasmosis
medical professionals are satisfied with
its effectiveness and any side effects
are manageable i've reached out to
turing pharmaceuticals which now goes by
the name viera pharmaceuticals to find
out how far long they've come in making
a new drug but i have not yet heard back
its website states it has completed
early stage studies to investigate the
safety of a novel molecule to treat the
parasitic disease just a few months
after the price hike shkreli resigned as
ceo of turin pharmaceuticals after being
charged with security fraud this had to
do with the two hedge funds he ran
before he switched careers the
securities and exchange commission
accused him of lying to investors in his
hedge funds about how much money they
had and what they were invested in and
in one instance lost 7 million in a
disastrous trade to pay back angry
investors prosecutors accused him of
ripping off another drug company that he
found it before touring called retrofin
in effect using retrofin as a personal
piggy bank to take millions in stock in
cash although the fraud charges were not
related to the dareprim case shkreli
believes the timing was no coincidence
it's ironic that the day they decide to
charge was just a few months after the
dare prime pricing in any case the
criminal charges didn't seem to bother
him much he made faces in court he
boasted in one of his many live streams
that if he got acquitted he'd sleep with
a female journalist he previously
harassed on twitter which got him banned
from that platform reporter lauren duka
responded i'd rather eat my own organs
so much as touch me and i'll gladly chop
off one of yours
it appears he thought he'd win the case
spirit of harambe will guide over this
trial
justice will be served we're going to
win by a landslide but that's not how it
played out
on august 4 2017 a jury found him guilty
on three counts of securities fraud
before sentencing shkreli had tears in
his eyes as he gave a statement
admitting i was never motivated by money
i wanted to grow my stature in my
reputation
i'm here because of my gross stupid and
negligent mistakes i made
this was a very different martin shkreli
than the one the world had come to know
he was free in a 5 million bond while
awaiting sentencing but then the u.s
district judge revoked his bail and
threw him in jail judge kyo matsumoto
was not impressed when he encouraged his
facebook followers to grab strands of
hillary clinton's hair during her book
tour offering to pay five thousand
dollars a strand he said he wanted to
use the hair samples to prove clinton
was a murderer by comparing the hair
strands to the samples he already had in
another post he had offered a bounty to
find the person responsible for the
murder of democratic national committee
staffer seth rich shkreli's lawyers
explained he was joking but the judge
didn't think it was funny and she
revoked his bail
shkreli ended up with a seven year
sentence he also had to forfeit the
seven million he made from the fraud to
the federal government including giving
up his precious woontang clan album
the u.s department of justice sold the
album to a group of nft investors who
reportedly paid 4 million for it
shkreli was released from prison in may
2022 after serving five years of his
sentence prison was weird it's not what
it's like in the movies it's mostly just
guys kind of like
hanging out playing cards um
not doing anything too exciting gonna
probably make some babies you know
repopulate america we're having a
fertility crisis in this world so
it's important for me to do my job i
think i'm just gonna
have like 10 or 20 kids and just genghis
khan the world
minus the you know the
negative side of that
consent version
what else does his future hold besides
spreading his seed he's been giving
stock advice on his youtube channel he
says he plans to release his debut album
god's gift
and then there's his drug discovery
software platform he technically can't
work in the pharmaceutical industry a
federal judge banned him for life and
it's not clear if his new venture
violates the ban
the federal trade commission and seven
u.s states had sued shkreli they accused
him of tightly controlling the
distribution of darapim making it harder
for competitors who wanted to produce
generics to get samples for required
testing the patent on dareprim expired
years ago so other companies could have
produced a generic version to bring down
the cost
u.s district judge denise cote found
shkreli violated federal and state laws
that ban anti-competitive conduct she
called the dare prim scheme particularly
heartless and coercive and ordered him
to pay nearly 65 million in profits to
the states that sued him and i'm going
to be fighting that ban and winning i'm
going to hand him a nice big fat l
um and then throw a parade when i win as
for his former drug company vieira has
agreed to pay 40 million to settle the
government lawsuit over the price hike
it no longer has a monopoly on daraprim
starting in 2020 the fda approved
generic versions of dareprim instead of
750 dollars a pill the non-profit 46
brooklyn that looks into drug pricing
found the generics are around 300 which
is still expensive however ben link with
46 brooklyn pointed out to me if the
price of the brand never skyrocketed as
much the generics would likely be
cheaper
shkreli said in a recent reddit ama that
he still trades but he expects this
coming year to be brutal for stocks and
love him or hate him it seems like he's
right because the stock market is having
its worst start in 50 years and the us
economy is on the brink of a recession
with some saying it's already here
that's why it's important to diversify
your portfolio with alternative assets
like gold real estate and art
the new york times says when stock
markets take a nosedive people look to
invest in art that's why i'm partnering
with masterworks masterworks lets you
invest in multi-million dollar paintings
by famous artists like andy warhol
picasso and banksy just like buying
shares in tesla you can buy shares in
these artworks that have been
securitized by the sec these four
paintings gave a net annual return of at
least 27
even through covid a bear market and
rising inflation not to mention art had
an average yearly appreciation of 33 the
last time inflation was this high
according to masterworks all art index
masterworks is flooded with demand as
people are looking to diversify so there
is a wait list but you can skip the
waitlist by clicking my custom link in
the description for priority access
that's masterworks dot art slash
newsthink masterworks dot art slash
newsthink thanks for watching for
newsthink i'm cindy palm